blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman i want to start today with a
story that several of you sent me about
a black democratic leader who threatened
uh who was threatened with lynching
for criticizing the former president
donald trump let's go right to the new
york times article iowa democratic chair
says he received lynching threat after
criticizing trump ross wilburn the first
black person to lead iowa's democratic
party said he received several racist
messages after writing a column in the
des moines register iowa's democratic
party chair said on tuesday he received
a lynching threat and several other
racist phone and email messages after he
wrote a column in the state's largest
newspaper denouncing former president
donald trump and republicans the party
chairman ross wilburn the first black
person to lead the democratic party in
iowa the presidential proving grounds
said that he turned the messages over to
the police in ames iowa and planned to
press charges if the people who sent the
messages were identified speaking to
reporters over zoom mr wilburn a state
representative from ames said that the
threatening messages were in response to
an october 8th opinion article that he
wrote in the des moines register titled
iowa republicans put loyalty to trump
over helping iowans the columns
publication preceded trump's rally in
iowa
his first visit since losing in 2020 and
since the january sixth insurrection
wilburn said tuesday at some point we
have to say enough is enough we can't
control thoughts that people filled with
hate have but when you speak out when
you choose to act in certain ways that's
when it's not okay on october 8th
wilburn said he received a voicemail
from a restricted number ending with a
threat that included a reference to
lynching over the next two days he said
racial slurs were repeatedly directed at
him in another voicemail and an email
sent to his legislative account
commander jason tuttle of ames police
department
said in an email that wilburn filed the
police report and police
were investigating you know one of the
things he there's so many layers to the
the speech rights that the right likes
to claim it's not shocking
that the pro-trump people when they got
angry with a black guy for criticizing
trump they said racist things to him
that's not a shock that's kind of like
blase in a sense sadly but it but it is
at this point we've become very very
used to it you know they really have
this
confounding convoluted understanding of
speech
when it comes to as we talked about
yesterday
the right being angry
that stories they want to see in the
mainstream don't get enough attention
because they're dumb stories
they say that it's suppression of speech
now of course
media outlets and people can choose i
want to talk about this or i don't want
to talk about that it's not necessarily
an indication of suppression of speech
or censorship or self-censorship some
stories are just kind of dumb
then
when there are consequences to their
speech
they say
well that's a restriction of my freedom
of speech no you were allowed to speak
and say what you wanted about the
election results or about lab leak or
hunter biden or whatever but also there
are reactions to your speech by people
who themselves have the right to speak
as well
but they don't like that that that's not
good
but then here
instead of this just being a reaction a
consequence to the speech of mr wilburn
they actually go over the line because
threatening people with a lynching or
with a personal injury or calling them
and leaving repeated racial slurs
those may be the consequences to will
burn speech but that goes beyond into
criminality because those are now
threats and its harassment so like on
every level on this speech thing
enforcing terms of service is not a
first amendment violation it's not even
the government
it's a private company enforcing their
terms of service
reaction to the thing i said well now my
speech is being suppressed by that
speech no it's just the consequence of
your speech and as long as it's not
illegal threatening or otherwise against
the law it's just something you have to
deal with when you speak people might
react to that okay well then i'm going
to react to what will burn said by
threatening with a lynching no that
actually is a crime at this point in
time it's a continued and persistent
misunderstanding of every aspect of what
free speech censorship and the ability
to say what you want to say and media
outlets to cover what they want to cover
they misunderstand all of it at every
single level obviously in the case of mr
wilburn let's hope they actually find
the people who uh made those horrible
racist threats
speaking of threats uh congressman matt
gates
who continues to be
um
at risk of uh being charged for a number
of different things including possibly
trafficking a minor a sex trafficking a
minor he gave a very strange speech on
the floor of the house on wednesday
where he said he thinks someone may be
trying to kill him
and
let's take
let's take a listen to what he had to
say i'd like to yield the first two
minutes uh to my colleague from florida
representative gates without objection i
thank the gentleman for yielding because
i think someone may be trying to kill me
and if they are successful i would like
my constituents and my family to know
who stopped their arrest madam speaker
on october 8 2021 a twitter handle uh
styled cia bob is at your door tweeted
two at rep matt gates lookee here pal i
lived in portland portland has ordered a
hit on you
i accepted the contract have a good day
following this tweet this individual
traveled to washington d.c and the
capitol police
recommended his arrest that's
information that was just shared with me
by the investigations and threat
assessment section of the protective
services bureau and specifically george
desesso and george shared with me that
the capitol police recommended the
arrest of this individual and that the
department of justice
refused to do so declined to do so and
on the eve of the attorney general
testifying before the judiciary
committee tomorrow it is just yet
another example of the department of
justice having a double standard so
we don't know how much of this is true
if someone threatened him on twitter and
then fluted across presuming it's
portland oregon flew across the country
to washington dc that individual should
be arrested if the individual wasn't
arrested and everything else is true we
should know why if the department of
justice said don't arrest we should know
why but imagine if the floor of the
house was taken over
by members announcing every threat that
they get on twitter
um you know
there's so many questions here including
whether gates is even telling the truth
about this but in all seriousness
often
death threats are not something you want
to announce publicly because it
encourages way more of them i told this
story once long after it took place
of someone who had been sending me
threats and i didn't mention anything
about it at the time for years
i ultimately learned
that the fbi
went to the house of this individual and
it was someone living very rurally
the way it was described by the fbi it
was
an extremely um
uh
man i don't i don't want to be insulting
but the fbi said this is someone without
the resources or volition to carry out
the threats and imagine if all along i
had been announcing the fact that this
threat was going on and it ended up
being a particular threat of no
consequence or significance at all but
all the time people are hearing about it
and it's encouraging copycats and it's
encouraging more threats and that type
of thing i just don't know other than
grandstanding and other than trying to
make some statement of political bias
that the department of justice only
wants to protect democrats from death
threats and not republicans or something
like that
i don't even know why this is being
discussed on the floor of the house and
of course in the meantime understand
that matt gates is under investigation
by federal authorities for sex crimes
that's really what the focus should be
and i read one comment that said he's
just already trying to argue that
federal authorities have a bias against
him to if he is indeed charged by those
same departments if the doj ultimately
charges him he can come in and maybe try
to use his defense listen they
these people have it out for me when we
reported a death threat and that the
capitol police said the person should be
arrested they didn't even do it
i don't know if matt gates has that
amount of foresight maybe it's his
lawyers i don't know it's certainly
plausible but not something we actually
have evidence is the motivation for him
doing this but a very strange
declaration to be making on the floor of
the house both for security reasons
about not publicizing threats and
because of the fact that he's currently
being investigated by federal
authorities for a bunch of different
pretty serious crimes let me know your
thoughts you can find me on twitter at d
pacman we'll take a break and we have a
lot coming up for you today
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
remember that the david pakman show is
made possible primarily by viewers and
listeners who sign up on our website and
get themselves a membership members
memberships are cheap
they're easy to sign up for takes about
a minute with average computer skills
um and you get access to great stuff
like the bonus show commercial free
streams of the show on and on
you can sign up at joinpakman.com and if
you want a discount you can use the
coupon code better21
let's take some calls from people we do
calls now via discord you can join the
discord at
davidpakman.com slash discord let's
speak first today
to ryan from maryland ryan from maryland
you were on the air
hey david how's my audio is it okay it's
beautiful
all right fantastic
um my second time talking to you so
appreciate you taking the call
so
i i work i'm a cyber security
professional kind of the dc maryland
area and i've always been
really interested in getting your take
on kind of the political ramifications
of cyber attacks
so you know there's there's a lot we
look at things like the colonial
pipeline attack um trace to dark side
which is an eastern european group we
look at the solar winds attack um apt-29
eastern european group you know there's
there's a clear asymmetry in
in our response naturally so right is
like how do we respond at a political
level
um to these kind of ambiguous
or at least attacks where the damage is
kind of ambiguous right and yeah you
know i think it's cooler if there's if
we're you know attacked in a major city
you know the the the carriers go out to
the ocean and we have a clear military
response but for these it's kind of a
more subtle
um
political engagement um between you know
it may not be government to government
but i've always been curious like how do
we measure what is an appropriate
response from a kind of a political
perspective when we can clearly trace
through cyber forensics that there's
likely a government
involvement in some of these these kind
of infrastructure attacks this is a
really tough question one approach to
saying okay if you believe that there
should be an equivalent response when
something like this is done your first
step would be how do we quantify the
damages this would be one way to
approach it so you would have to do an
analysis and say
what dollar value can we put on the
damages what human value can we put if
nobody died but there were two billion
dollars essentially in damages do you
just turn around and say
how do we do 2 billion in damage to the
country that did this without killing
anybody like is it that utilitarian that
this is sort of a new front in a sense
so i don't know you know there's i
recently read a book
uh by it's a real page-turner i read it
on vacation by um by robert ludlum who
wrote the bourne you know born supremacy
born
all those books
a different one
where there's a group that wants to
poison the american water supply uh they
identify i think it's like five or seven
aquifers or whatever the case may be and
you know they have this plan and it's
like that that could kill
an untold number of people and it seems
much more clear-cut
for better or worse what kind of a
reaction you would see the government
take in such a situation against the
offending country with some of the
things you're thinking about it's much
more complex and i don't i don't
immediately know how we quantify what
our response should be
yeah that that's that's really it is is
sometimes it's
it's unquantifiable right it's like
there's a lot of qualitative damage that
we can assess but it's hard to kind of
put numbers around it absolutely and i
think one of one of my other concerns is
you know i'm seeing some of the work i
do is on
um ics which is like industrial control
systems and so a lot of our
infrastructure water supply power grid
that has been intentionally not
connected to the internet for a very
long time and they're starting to
they're starting to bring this
infrastructure online um which is
obviously opening it up you know from an
attack vector perspective and and so i i
think
you know some of the dialogue around
what a political response would be in
the event of these infrastructure
attacks is is going to is definitely
going to have to ramp up as we start to
see
more and more attempts at kind of
disrupting this infrastructure so i
think it's a it's kind of an interesting
front and and you're right i mean i
think there's no clear answer at least
not yet
um especially in situations where the
damage is a little bit more subtle and
unquantifiable but yes um
yeah and you've got to be you've got to
make sure as you bring these systems on
on the internet that they are adequately
robust in terms of being protected and i
think that's one of that's one of the
concerns as that starts to happen as
you're pointing out
yeah i mean and these systems are super
antiquated right so bringing these
online is is such a challenge and um and
just seeing how vulnerable even really
complex systems are um it does give me
uh it i wouldn't say it keeps me up at
night but it does it does give me some
some concern um from what i see at kind
of the the professional level but um
yeah interesting to see kind of how this
plays out from a political perspective
in the future but i wanted to get your
tape from that so i appreciate you uh
you taking the time thank you important
topic great to hear from you um
something i'm sure we will be addressing
again
let's go next to
audrey from
georgia audrey you are on the air
hi david uh i believe we've we've uh
talked before
excellent um but i had an interesting
question for you i was on yesterday one
day
so i was i
studied chinese in college and i was
talking with my chinese professor
yesterday now sorry i'm sorry to
interrupt
did you study mandarin or cantonese
mandarin ah okay good
and i came to the conclusion that i
think china is a little bit like
kind of i think we treat them very
biased in our media and especially in
our education
and i want to get your take on that do
you think that china in many ways is
sort of like demonized in our media like
if you look in the news it's always
something bad about them there's never
any reports on like
the the good things going on in there
like scientific research and everything
yeah i would generally speaking agree
that there is a i mean listen china is
an economic adversary there is no
question about that but they're also an
economic partner and that's what makes
this so complex on the one hand we have
an economy that for decades has been
based on being able to get cheap stuff
from china that's what it is if we
didn't get cheap stuff from china and we
couldn't quickly get it elsewhere and
had to bring all production domestically
we'd be buying american as some people
say but things would cost dramatically
more and what i see is an asymmetry in
if we want to recognize china as an
economic adversary and along with russia
up there with the us as being in a
battle to be the major of the three
major superpowers that's fine that's
accurate i have no problem identifying
china in that way
but
so many of the people who wildly talk
about china virus and intellectual
property theft and this stuff
seem to not know
or or recognize
that our entire way of life including
the purchasing power that we have is
based on the fact that we manually we
get so much of our day of our of our
products from china and i think it would
be great to have a more balanced
perspective on that
all right and uh
i was more talking about um also like in
education very few people in the united
states seem to know anything about like
the politics or the general like daily
life of what it's like for people in
china they just see that's not super
surprising though that it's very common
that people people in the united states
also know very little about the lives of
people in russia
or in japan or in denmark now you could
say well china's more important to know
about for the reasons you're laying out
but it's not surprising that u.s
education at least at the k through 12
level is very u.s senate i mean like in
in u.s education we learn all about how
the japanese and british
parliament and everything works but
there's absolutely no involvement in now
uh other countries such as like how
russia's or how china's
politics work and i think it's something
important that we need to recognize if
we're going to have those important
political discussions all over the news
about you know like china getting rid of
term limits or anything if you're going
to understand that you have to have at
least a basic knowledge of how it works
i agree with you i agree with you
completely audrey thank you for the call
you're welcome all right there is audrey
let's go
next to oh we don't often get calls from
idaho let's go to barbara from idaho
hi david can you hear me barbara i can
hear you fine
or at least i could are you still there
barbara is gone that's too bad barbara
left
i was really looking forward to that i i
would love to know what like what's
happening in idaho it's a very
it's a closed book for me let me put it
that way let's go to tyler from st louis
tyler you're on the air
hey david i'm not eating a sandwich this
time okay good
um
i guess i didn't really have a question
i just wanted to apologize to the pacman
community for subjecting their ears to
that
you listened back and the the sandwich
eating was a distraction during your
last call in other words
oh certainly yeah yeah yeah well listen
i think uh i think apology accepted now
we've we've sorted it out
all right that's all i had to say okay
good but next time definitely mute the
discord blings that would be what the
thing to work on for the next call
yeah there's another one yep
yeah that's
something to do to push to talk i don't
know how to turn that off uh i have no
idea why my microphone picks that up
yeah all right very good thank you for
the call we've gotten everything up to
date as far as that's concerned let's go
next to nate from rhode island nate you
are on the air
nate from rhode island you're on the air
and nate from rhode island gone wow
things taking a turn let's see if chris
from baltimore can save us chris you are
now on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can
okay wow that's crazy
well um
i just wanted to ask a random question
basically like if you had uh
if you were the president and you had
executive order
for you know privileges sure what would
be the first
executive order you passed assuming you
could only do one what would you do
i have no idea it's such a weird i mean
the thing about these questions they're
almost sort of like would you rather
only eat avocados for the next five
years or have to do a thousand sit-ups
before you could drink water each day
it's like i don't know it's unlikely to
ever be a scenario um if i could oh i
don't i don't know what it would be i
mean here's the thing
if i was really going to be in the
position of getting to sign one
executive order
first i would want to be fully briefed
as to all of the things that can even be
done via executive order so that i could
be informed and really evaluate like i
could just say to you oh the first thing
i would do is i would forgive student
dad some student debt or something like
that
if i knew the full scope of what a
president could do via eo
i might say something completely
different so i don't know i'm i'm not
good at these kind of forced questions
let me ask you a question
uh
if if the only breakfast you could eat
for a year was oatmeal with hot dogs in
it or
apples which one would you go with
i see what you're trying to say
i mean
probably the hot dog option wow that's
crazy for me that's an easy question i
would go with the apples but okay that's
fair all right
david thank you so much man i'm a huge
fan my pleasure thanks for calling in
there's chris
from baltimore um let's take a very
quick break if you're holding
hang on for me we're going to go right
back to the phones in a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right let's get back to your calls
via discord find the
davidpakmanshowdiscord davidpakman.com
discord very very easy
it works beautifully i mean really
really beautifully
let's go um oh i'm told nate from rhode
island now knows what to do to talk to
me nate from rhode island you are on the
air
hi david my mic was muted last time how
you doing i'm doing well thank you
so i had a question what is the best way
to oust mansion in cinema apart from
voting them out at the next opportunity
well that's the only way as far as i
know you've got to vote what what other
ways do you have in mind i hope you're
not talking about like an assassination
no no no
how else do you get him out other than
them losing an election or retiring
um i was curious is there a way to like
like i don't know if the whole vote of
uh no confidence thing is actually a way
to oust them out if that's just like a
formal thing no i think it's just a
formality i mean listen here's here's
the thing i think bill share actually
said it really really well
uh this this applies more to mansion
than to cinema
um it would be very hard to replace
mansion with a more liberal democrat
right so
without mansion right now
democrats don't even have a majority and
mitch mcconnell prevents all of the
things we're talking about from even
being on the floor of the senate so
really you've got to replace some
republicans with democrats that actually
is what needs to be done mansion in west
virginia i don't know like if you manage
to defeat him in a primary
that person almost certainly loses the
general election yeah so i i just don't
know i mean i i over i didn't overstate
right after the november 2020 election i
said
joe manchin's going to be a problem and
a lot of people wrote to me and they
said sir you're overstating that and i
said no and it turned out that i and
others were right but the solution isn't
replace you know get mansion out and
have a republican be in a seat it's we
got to flip some republican seats
yeah i'm hoping to get more progressives
in the 2022 midterms fingers crossed
with that yeah there's we have i haven't
done a full breakdown of what's possible
in the senate in 22 it's not impossible
but it's going to be an uphill battle
yeah it makes sense all right thanks for
the call david all right thank you uh
thanks for calling me i should start
calling people that's actually not a bad
idea i like that idea
let's go next to
let's go to ricardo from oklahoma
yes hi can you hear me i can hear you
excellent actually what a pleasure uh
what an honor actually pleasure um
my question to you is we talk a lot
about fake news
um
i want to
talk about social engineering do you
think fake news is social engineering
in what sense what in what way would it
be social engineering
so
fake news sounds very easy very uh
very simple you know somebody just post
something fake online and it's fake news
social engineering has
a more
a deeper purpose you know has a strategy
behind it like right now on youtube you
can see
uh commercials of donald trump saying
that he's asking a lot of people to
vaccinate and all that but he's also
actually asking for money somewhere else
so to me that's um kind of like social
engineering trying to have people
believe he's
he's a good person asking for people to
vaccinate yet
uh to me that's that that's a way to ask
for money and convince people to to get
money uh
you see what i'm saying so the the
definition of social engineering is
some kind of central plan to manage
social change and regulate the behavior
of a society
so the way that fake news could be
social engineering would be if one view
of fake news would be
fake news spreads really easily
and so it's profitable and so
individually all of these purveyors of
fake news put out fake news not to
influence society but just to make money
like that would be fake news not being
social engineering you could say fake
news with social engineering if there
was a concerted effort in order to
influence people to behave a certain way
on the basis of fake news that is being
spread so like you could say maybe
there's a social engineering motivation
for fake news spread about the vaccine
and that would be
to further some political goal or to
cause chaos at school board meetings or
whatever the case may be so sure i mean
in that sense
the coordinated spread of fake news
could be a form of social engineering i
don't know that we've we know that to be
the case necessarily
okay
i appreciate your time and your show
it's a great show great source of
information and knowledge and i
appreciate you taking my call thanks
ricardo i appreciate you calling in uh
interesting interesting uh for for sure
let's go
next as we take phone calls
let's go to let's go back to rhode
island let's go to jen from providence
rhode island
hey david can you hear me yes i can jen
all right um is it some speaker weird um
all right so i have a question um i know
that you're interested in social and
history and everything sure have you
looked into what happened after the 1918
pandemic how there was a similar kind of
labor shortage and how workers used it
to demand higher wages and there was
kind of a social movement going on and
then the teamsters rose up that's very
good
yeah do you think we're kind of
repeating history with that and we might
be able to use this to our advantage to
get better wages yes in fact i did a
story on the wednesday show
about the spread of strikes and worker
protests across the country
and made the point that the pandemic may
have generated
the you know ideal maybe is a little too
much but favorable conditions for
workers to use newfound leverage uh to
demand better working conditions and
better wages now as far as 1918 and the
flu
i did not know i've studied the 1918
pandemic a bit and we've done one or two
interviews about it
i didn't know about the um impact there
on strikes and worker rights
beyond just it was the tail end of the
progressive era during which we saw
activism for wages and better working
conditions but as as
ushered in by the pandemic i wasn't
familiar with that and i will look into
it that sounds interesting
yeah and it was uh kind of the same
thing that was going on now there was a
huge wage gap
and uh those workers that for the first
time were able to afford things like
automobiles and appliances that were
just coming into existence the middle
class rose to be until the you know 1929
when the stock market crashed
so i kind of wonder you know we're at
the same wage gap that maybe we could
kind of make up some of the space yeah
like what they did 100 years ago that i
mean it's it's possible and we're going
to keep following these strike movements
and see see what they develop and you
know i would
from a from a self-centered standpoint i
would love that and a lot of times
people say david i don't understand like
why are you saying it would be good for
you
for workers to earn higher wages like
what how does that affect you and as
i've explained so many times before
the way i earn money is by people
getting memberships on my website and
buying the products and services sold by
my advertisers that's how that's how i
make money if an advertiser does well
they buy more ads
and so
if more people
have disposable income they're not
living paycheck to paycheck
that's dramatically growing the pool of
people that can afford to get a
membership or buy something from an
advertiser so i am thrilled about these
protests because i think that they're
the right thing and that workers deserve
rights and also from a selfish
standpoint as an entrepreneur it's great
for me as well and and so i don't get
the uh um wholehearted opposition that
we see from so many places
yeah i'm in a similar boat as that i'm a
waitress and people are gonna tip more
if they have a little bit of extra money
in their pocket absolutely it's demand
side stimulus and whether you know that
that's what it is or you don't working
people understand that when people have
more money it's also better for me
yeah and just better for the economy
overall and better for you know
depression things like that people are
just happier absolutely yeah all right
well i thank you you are my favorite
youtuber and hey it's my birthday
tomorrow so this is a good early
birthday present all right happy early
birthday jen from providence great to
hear from you
um
really really strong phone calls today
it's actually shocking me
uh let's see where do we want to go next
let's try let's go north of the border
let's go to alex from quebec
hi david can you hear me yes i can
bienvenue
uh merci beaucoup i'm actually a first
time caller and
before the pandemic in quebec the pro
the government had promised electoral
reform
away from first past the post and
into a mixed member proportional
representation system sure but
among the advocates of electoral reform
there was a big debate between
those who wanted proportional
representation
and those who preferred uh well a
preferential voting system
justin trudeau actually was
more of an advocate of the second option
while the provincial government
preferred the first option
and i was just wondering uh what was
your preference between the two well i
you know i i always hesitate to weigh in
specifically about
questions in front of other countries
because i just don't feel as as if i'm
as well informed as i could be or should
be really to be commenting
but i've talked over the years about a
number of different
reforms to how we do our elections that
i would welcome
i would love a proportional
representation system big picture
because it could be a way for third
parties to make inroads in the united
states the risk of course is you get
five percent white supremacists or
something crazy and that's something
that that would have to be dealt with
and we would have to think about that
but i think proportional representation
especially in the us where this
two-party duopoly is a complete and
total mess would be an interesting thing
switching away from first past the post
to something like single transferable
vote or one of the many different ranked
choice voting systems that don't have
some of the problems that we've
identified in a few of the systems would
also be very much welcome a combination
of the two is something that i would be
open to i welcome that uh and in the us
i've talked about a lot you know in the
context of canada it seems more
appropriate to ask someone who's been
following the canadian discussion
well uh
in my honest opinion yes uh
everyone just advocates for the reform
that advantages them generally so for
example
yeah justin trudeau leads a centrist
party so of course he will prefer a
preferential voting system because
if he ends up against the right-wing
candidates he'll get the left-wing vote
and if he ends up against the left-wing
candidates he'll get the right-wing vote
whereas in quebec where the main issue
has been um
nationalists not in the sense of like
white nationalists as an america but
nationalist as in wanting more autonomy
for the province wanting to protect the
french language and so on of course uh
yeah usually these parties have
uh split the vote between
left and right wing nationalists
allowing for um
well parties who aren't that to win more
seats than they should have and so
quebec nationalists of course prefer a
proportional voting system
to
uh increase their representation yeah on
that on that front what what are the
rules right now in terms of the signage
in quebec is it that they the signs have
to be only in french or it has to be
french first and larger
uh well
in the 70s they tried to make it only in
french
and the supreme court of canada said
you're not allowed to do that that's
infringing on freedom of speech okay and
so today it's
predominantly french that means you can
put it in english
but
the font has to be smaller than in
french understood i think
i think there's an exception in native
communities where
uh you are allowed to have signages only
in like inuit or euron or stuff like
that because yeah we we want to protect
french but we don't want to like
end native languages
day-to-day
what's the how much french versus
english are you speaking is it 90 10 is
it
i i almost
don't well i live in a rural region so
far away from
uh montreal where in montreal you need
english yes but
outside of that
uh you don't really need to i only
learned to speak english at 14. okay so
it really wasn't a necessity in my
day-to-day life yeah understood
understood
all right very good at fascinating to
hear about what's going on in quebec i
appreciate the call
all right thank you david all right
thank you
um
really great topics today really really
great topics let's speak to
oh i don't know how about um
is this is this jake from massachusetts
hold on is it oh no it's do not call on
did not want me to call on sorry but wow
i apologize somebody was just
they left a note saying don't call on me
and it just looked so interesting that i
had to go with it let's go to michael
from berlin michael you're on the air
hey david yes great to hear from you
pleasure i'm actually berlin new jersey
oh i don't have an accent but um well
actually you do have an accent but it's
a jersey accent
yes yes yes thank you i visited germany
13 times though
uh because my
parents are from austria
uh so i'm a first generation australian
american now let me let me inquire about
that you went to germany 13 times
because your parents are from austria
why not go to austin
i'm sorry uh to clarify frankfurt
airport
uh
went from frankfurt to uh vienna austria
got it and uh so that was about 13 times
uh through frankfurt got it
uh so i'm a little nervous this is the
first time i've ever called any show
you're doing great so far uh this is
actually on my bucket list so i
and that that's one of the things that
asks you what was on your bucket list oh
i i don't i don't have any i don't ever
think about the in those terms
unfortunately i'm i couldn't yeah i
don't have a bucket list
okay um well my bucket i just wanted to
give an example my bucket list would be
to travel the united states i'm into
endurance events and i would love to go
for a long distance bike tour
of the us
and just meeting people and discussing
um
you know
meeting with different people and
talking about uh you know other things
local things
you know just learning learning from
different cultures in the us and maybe
talk about democracy how we can help our
uh our democracy uh get along because
people don't understand the process of
just getting involved in local politics
absolutely that seems like a worthy
thing
yeah well i mean i need to leave of
absence though that won't take me like a
month or a couple months to do but oh
yeah i would set aside some time for
that
yeah i'd like to shout out to uh eggbert
as well who was from vienna he was a
caller and he hasn't called in for a
while and i've really enjoyed his uh
his uh
you know when he called in
all right very good shout out to egbert
from austria i so appreciate the call
we are going to speak to a couple of
other people here let's go to
um tony
from philly tony from philly you're on
the air
hello
hello
you sound like you're completely
underwater what are you saying
how about that do i sound better now you
you know now it's perfectly clear yeah
okay um
what uh well first off hey david how you
doing i'm doing that thank you thank you
thank you
uh last time i called them we actually
spoke about uh reparations and i was a
little upset because you titled the
video caller uh argues about reparations
and it was more of a discussion and not
an argument but
okay all right
we'll investigate
small small potatoes you know sometimes
those uh you know i enjoyed my
discussion with you about it it wasn't
uh there wasn't any real issue that i
had with you labeling it that way just a
little joke all right what's on your
mind today
uh i wanted to
say how
i think what we need to do is really
amend the constitution to get 50 control
of the corporate boards of directors
uh in order to really get control over
this political environment i i think
people need to be in direct control of
the workplace and that's the natural
next step uh okay let's explore let's
explore what you mean okay
get control of 50 who for who to control
50 of boards of directors
an employee board of directors uh uh
pretty much almost like
um
like a union except uh they would have
direct uh control 50 direct control so
maybe so half the seats let's talk
through it calmly so we can understand
it half the seats of the corporation's
board of directors would be held by
employees that presumably are not
executives right it's the their workers
yes okay
and
once a company reaches what size would
this start like i'm guessing this
wouldn't apply to like tiny little
businesses
only publicly traded companies or only
publicly traded
or a company that controls uh
uh
way too much of the market share for a
given industry what about like a huge
nonprofit with a thousand employees
that's not publicly traded would it
apply to them as well
you know honestly i haven't thought it
out that far
yeah i mean i like this idea this is
when we talk about democratization of
the workplace
outside of the context of me being
not of me not being when i i'm not a
socialist so just saying
the the the workers just automatically
own the company and that's it there's no
more private ownership like i'm not a
socialist so i don't support that but
when we talk about democratization of
the workplace saying that after a
certain level it is required to have
employee representation on a board
that's a great idea that's exactly the
type of thing that that i find
interesting so i you know
when you
when you say we need a constitutional
amendment i don't know if it's done
constitutionally corporations are
typically registered at individual
states maybe it's a state-by-state thing
i don't know the legality of it but i'm
fascinated by the idea i think you're
we're thinking uh we're thinking big
ideas here
okay well thank you for your time i
appreciate it i just wanted to bring it
up to you and see if i could get a yay
or nay out of you my pleasure thank you
so much for the call very much
appreciate it
that's gonna do it for today we took
some great calls we will take calls
again and we will now go to a very short
break and then be back with more of
today's show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right everybody
let's get to this week's mailbag an
increasingly popular segment people seem
to be loving this segment other than the
people who hate it and that's about i
don't know judging from my email it's
not a zero it's a non-zero number of
people no but the we keep getting more
and more emails and interesting things
so
let's just get right into it first
message from moose
moose says mr pakman sir
while eating lunch in the teacher's
lounge today i overheard some coaches
discussing the new vaccine in china with
a 58 fatality rate the conversation
quickly went into one of the coaches
telling everyone china's working on a
vaccine to get rid of our sight and
hearing because they already created
kovid which damaged our taste and smell
i long blinked and face palm what are
your thoughts
obviously it's all bonkers but what's
interesting about that
is
they seem to concede covid was created
to damage our taste and smell
so now they're going to make a vaccine
to get rid of our sight and hearing but
i thought the problem with covid was the
vaccine not the virus i thought the
point was the vaccine kills you
as you can see there are various
conspiracy theories that covid was
created to take away our damn to damage
our taste and smell
but that the vaccine which prevents that
for many people actually is what kills
you but then now they're going to do a
new quote vaccine in order to take take
people's sight and hearing it's all
completely incoherent it's all absolute
and complete nonsense it doesn't make
any sense and yet this type of stuff
keeps spreading i wonder where moose
maybe moose is a sign that moose is in
you know some part of the country with
with moose and
that's where you got a lot of teachers
who believe this stuff i don't know
would be interesting to know what school
district that is but those those people
are teaching some of your kids some of
your kids are being taught
by those folks that is horrifying that
is absolutely and completely horrifying
next email is from bill
bill says
ask this question
does steve scalise believe that his own
election was legitimate
same ballots
same election yeah this is something i
pointed out
i think it was in december
which is you've got all these people
saying the results of the presidential
election were bogus bogus can't be
trusted they're fake fraud whatever
but all of the other races on the same
ballots like the senators and the
members of congress and all that stuff
those are fine
how exactly did they pull that off and
that would have been this is a reference
to the interview that chris wallace did
with steve scalise that we looked at
last week where chris wallace was saying
did trump win or was it stolen from him
did trump win was it stole from you know
all this type of stuff
did biden win or was it stolen from him
and steve scalise basically answered the
question three or four different ways
none of which were actually direct
answers a great question would be
were there also the same degree of
irregularities and possible fraud in
your election steve scalise because you
were on those same ballots and i don't
know what he would say
um he'd probably have some kind of work
around would be by my prediction
next email is from chase chase says
david audits are okay
why not allow all those demanding audits
to have their way but first they have to
agree to some requirements number one
they must cover all audit expenses
including for experienced objective
observers two counting must be done in
publicly viewed areas
another number two must agree to no
access to personal voter information nor
voter machine tampering
and number three which is really number
four if they find verifiable significant
fraud then the taxpayers will reimburse
all reasonable expenses this would force
them to put up or shut up it sort of
would chase but the problem is that they
would they would still
uh fundraise for it so we
as they've been doing and trump was able
to raise tens of millions saying we're
going to use this money to fight voter
fraud and the like
so i don't really know
that that would be
the solution to bogus audits the the
bigger issue is what does it even really
mean to do an audit
and that's a word that's often used
which has different meanings or no
meaning at all
depending on where it's taking place and
so i think it's a bigger systemic
problem but i don't disagree that saying
you've got to pay
uh
is a good idea
in some cases they have paid or at least
they funded the process themselves it
hasn't really deterred too much but
certainly there should be a financial
disincentive from doing this unless they
you know really really believe it which
many of them i know don't
it could serve to dissuade some of this
nonsense behavior
next email today is from adrian
adrian writes in about autocracy fascism
and republicans
and says i watch your channel i watch
tyt and others i also occasionally look
at the opposite views to give myself
perspective smart thing to do
i'm becoming more and more worried about
2022 and 2024. we've become rather
comfortable in our post in our world
post world war ii but should we can we
say for sure that a new nazi party will
never happen again look at the grand old
party meaning the republican party and
those within it who have always been
there but due to trump and his rhetoric
now feel
they have the license to spout their
true nature as if it was commonplace
should make those of us with any
semblance of decency shudder with fear
yeah this this is a good point and i've
said many times before
anybody who who has the idea
x can never happen or x can never happen
again
needs to rethink that and be more
cautious hopefully certain things won't
happen or won't happen again but listen
you know when trump said at the state of
the union a couple of times
we will never be a socialist country
maybe we will
um unpredictable things happen and how
trump can say the u.s will never be
socialist what about in 100 years what
about 500 years we don't know that and
much the same way for people who say
nazism hitler stuff could never happen
again
um assuming it couldn't is part of what
could allow it to and that's why all of
this
uh drama
and delusion
related to the january six riots and the
slow-motion coup that now is being
discussed more and more
cannot be ignored should not be ignored
and that's part of why we continue to
talk about it
andrew wrote in about the microchip
shortage
and says sirs so much has been made of
the current microchip shortage and i
can't believe the nonsense that is being
spread
misinformation about shipping issues and
this is satire by the way and
manufacturing backlogs is reaching
ridiculous proportions it's very simple
every vaccine has a microchip
and now every booster will have one as
well
this
is why there is a microchip shortage
wake up sheeple
it's sad but even though i'm telling you
this is satire
i will get comments just if you're if
you're watching this on youtube right
now look down below
you'll see comments that don't realize
that that's satire it's satire it's a
joke it's poking fun at the
disinformation anti-vaxxers all right
everybody relax it's just satire trust
me it's satire
lukian wrote in
lukian says
david
you've been repeatedly accused
of being quote bought by big pharma
this is of course unsubstantiated
nonsense
an interesting response i believe could
be for you to share the following
stories
of how youtubers around the world are
being paid to promote anti-vaxx
conspiracies which is literally the
opposite of what you are accused of yeah
without evidence and without even
plausibility people accuse me of being
in the pocket of big pharma i'm getting
money from big pharma to promote the
vaccine now all i've ever done is report
the data and the statistics on vaccine
studies
but there actually are
anti-vaccine influencers and money
floating around to them
to question the efficacy of the vaccines
to promote alternative treatments as if
they are ironclad treatments for covid
um on and on and on that's actually
where the money is why would anyone pay
me to quote promote a vaccine
the data says it really protects you
from serious illness and death
we see the overwhelming number of deaths
among the unvaccinated i really went and
got the vaccine nobody paid me to go and
get it
uh why would anyone pay me to promote
the vaccine it doesn't make any sense
nor is there evidence that people are
being paid to promote it there is
evidence people are being paid to
promote
anti-vaxx ideas
sometimes it's soft anti-vaxxerism
which is talking about um
disproportionately focusing on side
effects
um or talking about there's plenty of
alternative treatments etc sometimes
it's straight up anti-vaxx like
conspiracy theory microchip 5g
your arm gets magnetized sort of stuff
there's a combination of both they're
the ones that we know some of whom have
gotten paid
next email i love these
oh david
you lie so much
it's scary
no wonder your channel is dying i really
love these
because it's so not true and it angers
them that the channels aren't dying we
actually had last week this is i don't
even know why this is happening
we had the best week last week for the
audio podcast
since the week of the insurrection
you've got to go back 10 and a half
months
for a week where we had
the same number of audio podcast
downloads as last week the audio podcast
has been exploding we have more
subscribers than ever on youtube we
reached 1.4 million i'm really excited
about getting to 1.5 million
uh we had something like 30 million
youtube views last month
extremely healthy number um and these
folks have been around for a long time
oh you're circling the drain
any day now you're gonna have you're
gonna be down to zero viewers
the show has never been bigger and it's
a really exciting thing to see all right
one last bonus message this one's from
facebooks
this one uh is from an unnamed an
individual whom i shall not name
who says you need to stop pushing lies
you're accusing this woman of lying you
were the liar the vaccine has not been
approved
you might as well move to venezuela or
nazi germany if that's what you think i
think it would be best for you to shut
up
not a single
punctuation mark not a single well i
guess the apostrophe in your and that's
count
not a single comma
not a single period
just
a run-on
this is the run-on from hell i guess is
what i would say
um and it's kind of funny also
venezuela
or nazi germany
both regimes which i oppose
for different reasons
and which have
very little
in common with each other sad stuff
sad stuff my friends
get your emails in for the mailbag info
davidpakman.com info davidpakman.com but
and this is a really serious thing
please don't email us every day please
don't email us multiple times a day
there are now probably about 50 people
in the audience
who relentlessly email us every single
day about things related to politics and
things not related to politics if you're
doing that
we almost certainly are not seeing your
emails when we see someone does this
stuff emailing in a dozen times a day
sometimes more
um and they clog our inbox it really
restricts our ability to go through and
find substantive material so we those
are getting filtered directly into the
trash
and just just think
am i emailing david every day am i
emailing david multiple times a day
if you are i we're not seeing we're
almost certainly not seeing the messages
because they're just being auto filtered
we just we just can't keep up with that
it's not what the mailbag and what the
email address is set up for you know
it's
let's let's uh let's be sensible my
friends let's be sensible uh email is
info
davidpakman.com
we have a phenomenal bonus show for you
today sign up at joinpackman.com to get
instant access
and we've got a whole new week of shows
coming up for you next week as well
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com
david pakman